jQuery comes with a bunch of Dom related
methods that make it easy to access and
manipulate elements and attributes in
this video I'm going to talk about
getting and setting content and
attributes so we have this line that has
some HTML here it's a paragraph tag with
a link inside it and then we have a
button here so I'm gonna use jQuery to
add a click event here so I'm going to
use jQuery to select the text within
this paragraph tag so we see the ideas
text so I'm going to use a selector to
get that so and I'm gonna console.log
the text so we're gonna do console dot
log and inside the console dot log I'm
gonna do a jQuery command so we're going
to select the paragraph tag because it
has an idea of test and then I'm gonna
use the dot text method this will get
all the text within the paragraph tag
but it will not get any HTML within the
paragraph tag so let's see what that
does
so if I click show content oh I was
wondering why that didn't work but I
forgot to put a pound sign or hash mark
here that's how we're gonna select the
ID to select something an idea to put
this this symbol here before it so now
let's try it if I click show content
it's gonna say learn to code with free
code camp and as you can see it's not
putting any of this anchor tag it's not
putting a href just like that but if
instead of doing text we put HTML here
now it's going to show everything
including any HTML within that so if I
click show content now you can see it's
going to put all this other HTML in here
if you put text it strips out the HTML
and just put the plain text but if you
put HTML it's going to show all the HTML
we can also get the attribute values so
we're gonna use the attr method instead
of selecting test here I'm going to
select the element with the FCC ID so
they
it's gonna be this link up here so I'm
going to get the href attribute I'm
going to put attr to get the attribute
and then inside the parentheses I'm
gonna put href let's show that and you
can see down here it shows what the link
is so we're getting the value from the
href tag let's create another button up
here and so that's show content it's
going to be set content and now I'm
going to show you how you can actually
set the content such as getting the text
in the HTML you can set it for this
Biden speed button - I'll just copy this
here button - and let's select that
element with jQuery
okay so we've selected the test element
and now we have the text method but this
time we actually put something inside
the parentheses when you put something
inside the parentheses instead of
getting the text we're setting the text
so let's try that let me run that oh god
but the parentheses there okay i'ma hit
set content and the text changes the
free code camp and aw is awesome so if
you put HTML in here it's not gonna work
let's show that now let's try this angle
let's do set content and it's going to
actually show that the HTML tags right
in here but if I change this into
instead of text I use the HTML method
and now here it's actually going to show
up as bold okay I'll I also want to show
you how you can update the value of an
input field but first have to create an
input field
okay now we have this input field right
now you can put your name and it's its
defaults to my name bol Carnes so we are
going to make another button where we
can set the the value of the input field
so I'm gonna do some more copying and
pasting to add a click event to this
third button we're not going to set the
HTML or anything and I'm going to put
button three here so this is what we're
gonna do we're going to use the jQuery
selector we've got get the input field
with the name ID instead using dot text
or HTML I'm gonna do dot Val to change
the value okay let's try that
if I click set value see the name
changes to Quincey Larson now all three
of the jQuery methods I just talked
about the the dot Tex HTML and Val also
come with callback functions the
callback functions have two parameters
so the first one is the index of the
current element and the list of elements
selected all the examples I showed we
were only selecting one element but you
can select all the paragraphs or all the
links all the buttons and so you're
gonna get the index of what so the the
callback the function is going to give
you the index of the current element the
list of elements and the original or old
value then if you want you can return
the string you wish to use as the new
value from the function so let's try
that up here I'm going to change this
back to text so we're going to put in a
callback function so remember the
parameters are the index and then we're
gonna put a ridge text so we have the
index in the original text and here's
what we're gonna put inside the callback
function will put return the old text is
going to be that orig text plus we're
just concatenated strings here so the
new text is gonna be now this is where
I'm gonna get this value from down here
and we're gonna just take out these bold
tags also to show the index we're gonna
put that in parentheses
okay so we're now going to set the text
of this to this whole thing right here
so let's run that to see what happens
there I'm going to click the set content
button so look what it changed you old
text learn the code with free code camp
new text freak okay and a sock it is
awesome index zero let's try something
see we have two paragraph tags we have
so this is that we have this paragraph
and we have this paragraph what I'm
going to do instead of selecting the ID
test I'm gonna select just the paragraph
tag now let's do what happens set
content so look it actually just set
content to both paragraph tags and it
old text long Dakota freako camp new
text rico camp is awesome index 0 old
text name new text freako cam is awesome
index 1 it's basically an array and the
the first index is 0 that's the first
paragraph tag and the second index is 1
that's the second paragraph tag but
let's just change that back here so you
can do that with text HTML method or the
attribute method ok well thanks for
watching my name is beau Carnes don't
forget to subscribe and remember use
your code for good